the Joe Rogan experience he's uh he's a
Bitcoin believer yeah I'm a Bitcoin hmm
hmm this is me hmm I'm like I don't
understand that and I probably never
will so I'm gonna stay over here yeah
that's good move
I just every little like a little
pyramid scheme II does it I don't know I
mean it's it's nervous it makes us
nervous at this point in my life I just
assume everything is a pyramid scheme
it's always like a trickle of you know
yeah if it could be proven to be as
stable or more stable than money I think
we just go for it that's what I think I
think why [ __ ] around why use all these
old crazy rich banker dudes money when
you could just do nerd money just
digital nerd money but all it would take
is people having to agree to it right
that's all it would take if everybody
just agreed to just use Bitcoin mm-hmm
or if everybody agreed to an implant
that had all your info on it and all
your your money don't you do that story
cool walk into your movie man you know
that's coming yeah someone's gonna give
you the benefits of it if you just put
this in your dick most of all they just
have it inserted it yeah but we all have
one you know yeah they haven't turned it
on yet it's in your pocket not your
wrist yeah well some people it's on the
wrist too I was I was texting one night
with the guys in the band this was what
really scared the SH out of me real I
got I got off social media while back
completely again I tried Twitter again I
told Jason Isbell I gave it a second
shot but I realized my kids are way more
interesting like I'm trying to you know
I just rather be writing a song or doing
something else right now but one night
all we were all had a group text going
on and somebody said something made a
joke there's a lot of 80s film buffs on
our band and somebody made a John Claude
Van Damme reference and do you live in
five minutes later I'm not in any way
exaggerating this all my wife and I are
sitting and watching TV surfing Netflix
and instantly is like my entire channel
is full of jean-claude van damme
selections and obviously what in the
[ __ ] is going on I've never watched a
jock laughs and damn film ever on
Netflix and now there's all
it's like somehow that got crossed
marketed to my television set just cuz
I'm on my telephone talking about this
[ __ ] guy freaked me out and I was
like no more I'm dumping everything
dude I've heard people tell me that they
were having conversations on the phone
with someone and then what they were
talking about showed up in their Google
ads on their on their laptop how's that
work how does that work
I don't know idea are they listening
constantly some geniuses yes yeah Edward
Snowden says yes but that but the fact
that it shows up in your Google ads
isn't that a little [ __ ] obvious I
mean that hasn't happened to me do you
think that's real 100 percent 100
percent look at Lee he looks like you
should have a Guy Fawkes mask on right
now slip on one of them [ __ ]
anarchists masks look at him he's
smiling over there a hundred percent
they're listening to us
god dammit Gmail's free for a reason you
know what's really good read it
definitely reading everything Wow it all
makes sense intense now I'm freaking out
Jamie thanks is that okay
you know who signed off on that how many
people have ever read those terms of
agreement I don't have you ever the
thing that's what I think yours when you
buy the Alexa yeah like yes yeah you're
buying yes those people are crazy having
those things in your house you talk to
and it listens to everything [ __ ] all
that that just seems like to hackable
it's all weird man it's getting and by
the way this is just the first drops of
water that's going through before our
roof collapses because it's coming
[Applause]